the war in afghanistan draws to a
conclusion as the taliban overrun
kandahar and threatened the united
states embassy in kabul and the american
academy of pediatrics says kids don't
need to see human faces anymore i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your quick
reminder that we had a really really bad
inflation report yesterday and we had a
really really bad inflation report the
month before that inflation in the
united states right now is it like a
20-year high and the reason for that is
because we are blowing out the spending
now would be an excellent time to
diversify at least some of your holdings
into a precious metal that has never
been with zero i'm talking about
investing with my friends over at birch
gold if you haven't yet reached out to
birch gold to diversify part of your ira
or 401k into a precious metals ira do it
today text ben's 47 47 47 get a free
information kit on protecting your
savings with gold i buy my gold from
birch gold they have an a plus rating
with a better business bureau countless
five star reviews thousands of happy
customers talk to them have them help
you safeguard your retirement savings
again i know the folks at berkshire have
been working with them for years and i
do in fact trust them the reality is
that you can't trust the centralized
government of the united states to keep
the dollar worth what it is currently
worth in fact if you had taken the
dollar and its value like 40 years ago
and then projected it out over the
course of time it'll be worth about 15
percent of what it is worth then now so
yes the government is in the business of
inflating the currency tax ben 247 4747
to claim your free no obligation
information kit and speak with a
precious metals expert on holding gold
and silver in a tax shelter to count
again text men to 47 47 47 protect your
savings today alrighty so
after 20 long years in afghanistan the
united states is pulling out we are not
pulling out for a good reason it would
be one thing if there was some actual
strategy attached to this or if the
united states were actually achieving
some sort of sensible goal the united
states however is not doing any of that
the united states is withdrawing from
afghanistan at a time when this is no
longer among america's endless wars in
order for a war to be considered endless
you actually have to be in a state of
continual warfare the united states
currently has or did have until joe
biden announced to withdrawal 3 500
troops in afghanistan the last combat
casualties in the united states from
american soldiers in afghanistan was on
february 8th 2020. it is currently
august 2021. that is not an active
combat zone you're more likely to be
killed as a cop in chicago than you are
to be killed as a combat soldier in
afghanistan if you're an american right
now okay but joe biden decided he wanted
a win and because he wanted to win and i
don't even know what he thought the win
was going to be we were going to pull
out precipitously from afghanistan now
i understand the argument that we were
never going to achieve our goal in
afghanistan if our goal was defined as
nation building this was never going to
be a thriving democracy it is literally
the most tribal place on earth there's
no history of democracy or liberality or
human rights
those things just
were not there until the united states
got there and so the idea that we were
going to graft western institutions onto
very inhospitable soil
that always seemed like a bit of a pipe
dream but there is still a rather
large-scale american interest in
afghanistan if you recall why we first
went there we didn't go there to build
democracy in afghanistan we went there
in order to deny al-qaeda a staging base
and because we had not done that in the
1990s al-qaeda used taliban occupied
afghanistan as a staging base for 911
and having 3 500 troops
taking control of the kandahar air force
base for example and ensuring that the
united states had the ability to send
out drone strikes the ability to work
with the afghan military to stage
attacks on terror bases the ability to
train the afghan military and provide
them backup and weaponry if they were
going to take on potential threats to
the united states that was always the
primary goal again the goal was never
primarily to turn afghanistan into a
democracy the problem is over time
because politicians have a very
difficult time just expressing what
america's interest is in terms of
foreign policy
american politicians tend to speak in
high flown beautiful terms about the
rise of democracy and the rise of human
rights and all the rest of this but if
you make that your primary driver then
you do become the world's policeman and
people start to miss why we went into
afghanistan in the first place which is
that al qaeda killed three thousand
americans on 911 and we'd said to the
taliban turn over osama bin laden and
they refused to do so and so we deposed
the dictators there the taliban
we replaced them with the northern
alliance there was a sort of
pro-democracy happening there in other
words we let our failure with the
secondary goal of establishing a
thriving democracy in afghanistan
overtake our primary goal which is to
continue to provide a base of operations
against terrorists in afghanistan and so
now we are withdrawing for no
discernible purpose at all and the
immediate effect of this as it was
always destined to be is that the
taliban are rushing right back in and
taking over according to the associated
press today the taliban captured two
major afghan cities the country's second
and third largest after kabul and a
strategic provincial capital on thursday
further squeezing the embattled
government just weeks before the end of
the american military mission in
afghanistan remember joe biden for some
odd reason decided that he wanted to
withdraw all american troops by
september 11th which i don't even
understand the symbolism there what in
the hell is the symbolism there
the symbolism of here's the group of
people who harbored the people who
committed 911 we're gonna pull out on
the 20th anniversary of that date and
hand the place back to those people how
is that even a symbolic win like who was
the constituency for this
it's always been a promise that
politicians have made right obama made
the promise he was going to withdraw
from afghanistan then he increased
troops because it turns out being the
president comes with seeing the intel
reports and then donald trump said he
was going to pull out of afghanistan and
then necessity meant that we had to keep
troops in afghanistan and then joe biden
because he's a dullard decided we're
just going to go ahead with this and it
doesn't matter what comes next
which is completely short-sighted and i
don't even see the political calculus
here because the american people don't
tend to care about foreign policy until
the heads start coming off right that's
the point where we care about foreign
policy so america doesn't care about
what's going on in syria but if the
media start blanketing the tv with james
foley being beheaded in syria suddenly
the american people are deeply concerned
about what's happening in syria half a
million civilians can die in syria and
we won't give a damn but the minute that
an american gets beheaded suddenly we
want our troops on the ground doing
something about it
right if there is tape that comes out of
the yazidis being attacked by isis then
all of a sudden we say why can't we do
something about that see america is
good-hearted but only in short spurts so
i don't understand what biden even
thinks he is doing here because you know
what the next footage is going to be and
it's going to be a taliban fighters
beheading people
we'll be back in there in six months in
fact as it turns out we might be back in
there inside of six hours the united
states is going to have to put thousands
of troops on the ground to evacuate the
us embassy in kabul
according to the associated press the
seizure of kandahar inherit marks the
biggest prizes yet for the taliban who
have taken 12 of afghanistan's 34
provincial capitals as part of a
week-long blitz the capture of the city
of ghazni meanwhile cuts off a crucial
highway linking the afghan capital kabul
by the country's southern provinces all
part of an insurgent push some 20 years
after u.s and nato troops invaded and
ousted the taliban government
while kabul itself isn't under direct
threat yet the losses and the battles
elsewhere further tighten the grip of a
resurgent taliban who are estimated to
now hold over two-thirds of the country
and continue to press their offensive
with securedly rapid
with security rapidly deteriorating the
united states plans to send in 3 000
troops to help evacuate some personnel
from the u.s embassy in kabul so just to
get this straight we are withdrawing 3
500 troops so we can send back in 3 000
troops to evacuate the u.s embassy in
kabul
and then when the videos hit the tv of
all the women being lined up and shot by
the taliban which is undoubtedly the
next thing that is going to hit your tv
then presumably we'll be sending in
another 3 000 troops again
this is just a replay of barack obama's
decision that we're going to pull all
troops out of iraq and then isis took
over and voila we were back in iraq
it turns out that when the united states
ends a war our opponents don't that is
not how wars typically end if you
declare that you have lost your opponent
simply fills the vacuum
according to the associated press
thousands of afghans have fled their
homes amid fears the taliban will again
impose a brutal repressive government
all but eliminating women's rights and
conducting public amputations at
stonings and executions peace talks in
qatar remain stalled though diplomats
met throughout the day
the latest us military intelligence
assessment suggests kabul could come
under insurgent pressure within 30 days
and that if current trends hold the
taliban could gain full control of the
country within a few months the afghan
government may eventually be forced to
pull back to defend the capital in just
a few other cities in the coming days if
the taliban keep up their momentum
the onslaught represents a stunning
collapse of afghan forces and renews
questions about where the over 830
billion dollars spent by the us defense
department on fighting training those
troops and reconstruction efforts went
especially as taliban fighters ride on
american-made humvees and pickup trucks
with the m16s slung over their shoulders
just delightful delightful stuff afghan
lawmaker samin barkazai
announced the city's fall saying some
officials there had escaped witnesses
described seeing taliban fighters once
detained at herod's prison now moving
freely on the street
in kandahar the taliban sees the
governor's office and other buildings
witnesses said the governor and other
officials fled the onslaught catching a
flight to kabul they declined to be
named publicly because the defeat has
yet to be acknowledged by the government
the taliban then opened up all the
prisons and let out all of the taliban
fighters who were there
ghazni provincial council member
amanullah khamrani alleged the
provincial governor and police chief
made a deal with the taliban to flee
after surrendering taliban video and
photos purported to show the governor's
convoy freely passing by insurgents as
part of the deal the afghan interior
ministry spokesperson mayor ways
stomach's eye later said the governor
and his deputies had been arrested over
that alleged deal the officials could
not be immediately reached for comment
so this is a full-scale disaster area
the usa air force b-52 bombers f-15
fighter jets drones and other aircrafts
were involved in fighting across the
country so for all the talk about how we
weren't involved in the fighting anymore
it turns out that we are involved in the
fighting we're just now losing
so well done everybody also nbc news is
acknowledging that al qaeda is rushing
back in who could have predicted this
except for every single sentient human
being
of which joe biden doesn't belong in
that cadre he's not a sentient human
being any longer he is a house plant but
reality remains reality according to nbc
news with the taliban steamrolling
across afghanistan u.s defense officials
are concerned a taliban takeover of the
country will allow al-qaeda to rebuild
and consolidate creating security
concerns well outside afghan borders
nearly 20 years after it planned the
september 11th attack from afghanistan
al-qaeda has a diminished presence in
the country senior officials say it's
only two or three hundred members or as
barack obama might state the jv squad
until it's not the jv squad anymore one
of the officials said they're not really
very large or what we would consider a
capable contingent but the security
vacuum left by the withdrawal of us
military forces could create an opening
for al-qaeda and other terrorist groups
to reorganize the official say
if the taliban take over the government
intelligence about al-qaeda is likely to
become even scarcer
and while the us will still maintain
authority to strike al-qaeda targets in
afghanistan there's no u.s presence on
the ground no no air force base which
means we have to use neighboring
countries to base our air force if we
decide that we want to launch some
strikes
according to marine general frank
mckenzie he said what we're here to do
is prevent al-qaeda and isis from being
able to reconstitute in the ungoverned
spaces generally of eastern afghanistan
and be able to plot attacks against our
homeland that threat is still here
today
he says if the pressure comes off i
believe they're going to regenerate
i think it's only a matter of time
before we see them assert themselves and
begin to plan attacks against our
homeland and of course that would be the
predictable result remember september
11th was the outgrowth of the united
states unwillingness to take on al qaeda
after the uss cold bombing after the
bombings of the american embassies in
kenya and tanzania you remember that
that that osama bin laden specifically
said that the united states was a paper
target a paper tiger and so the idea was
that
he had hit us over and over and over
again we hadn't done anything so
obviously we wouldn't do anything if he
hit our towers and if he hit the
pentagon
and then we kind of shocked him because
we actually did quite quite a lot but it
turns out that when you surrender
territory to some of the worst people on
earth they don't take that as you just
want peace they take that as you are
weak and you are foolish and then they
come after you
there's this sort of wishful thinking
that goes into so much of our foreign
policy these days that if we just
do the things that we want to do
everybody else will just fall into line
that is crazy
by the way the chances right now that
the united states embassy ends up
falling to the taliban really really
high maybe we avoid the sort of
insane imagery of the fall of saigon
where people are attempting to climb
onto helicopters but that will only be
because we station 3 000 marines outside
the us embassy while we evacuate the
place and then we leave an empty
building for the taliban to dance inside
of
joe biden says you don't see us
helicoptering people off roofs well
i have a feeling that we're going to see
something very similar
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling none whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
um it is extremely comparable what do
you mean they don't have the same
capabilities you mean the capabilities
that ho chi minh army had when they
invaded south vietnam and then took the
capital you mean exactly the same thing
that the taliban are doing exactly right
now
in what sense is this any different
like really
is there any difference at all it's
exactly the same thing we were achieving
many of our objectives in afghanistan
mainly the objective to maintain a base
of operations with which to fight
terrorism just as we achieved many of
our objectives in south vietnam
and then political actors decided that
surrender was preferable to any form of
success and so they just pulled that
precipitously while proclaiming victory
it's insane by the way taliban fighters
are apparently executing surrendering
troops so things are already going
fantastically well over there we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the simple fact that it can
be overwhelming to perform at your best
as you age you got career and family
staying in shape life can be very
stressful you start to slow down you're
not present when you want to be to
perform at your best physically and
mentally you can't let age beat you and
that's where m drive can help m drive is
the daily supplement for driven men who
don't want to slow down who refuse to be
tired every day and want to be the best
at what they do it's packed with
clinically tested ingredients that
support healthy testosterone levels
while helping you lose weight and stay
lean added vitamins and nutrients reduce
stress and boost your drive so you can
perform at your best find it at
walgreens and other retailers today or
visit
mdrive4men.com get 20 off your first
order with promo code ben they have free
shipping and a 60-day money back
guarantee so you have nothing to lose m
drive it's not for everyone it's for the
driven m that's the letter m drive
dot com promo code ben if that energy
level is starting to win and frankly as
you get older it's just going to you
should try m drive four men they've got
the free shipping the 60 day money back
guarantee so really give it a try and
see if it works for you m drive4men.com
get 20 off your very first order with
promo code ben today okay so the taliban
of course are doing what the taliban do
and they are already executing everyone
they come across according to abc news
as taliban forces advance on more
provincial capitals the us is warning
that its fighters are committing
atrocities that could amount to war
crimes the state department will also
begin reducing its staff levels at the
u.s embassy in kabul due to the evolving
security situation wait i was just
informed by joe biden there wouldn't be
anything like the fall of saigon that it
wouldn't be the invasion of the us
embassy and helicopters flying off the
roof and yet here i'm finding out that
the state department is saying that
they're reducing their staff levels at
the us embassy in kabul because of the
quote-unquote evolving security
situation which is a nice euphemistic
way of saying because we are
deliberately abandoning the country
to facilitate this decision the pentagon
will temporarily deploy additional
personnel to hamid karzai international
airport
the u.s embassy in kabul has also urged
americans to evacuate afghanistan
immediately
so get out right now so yeah this sounds
pretty much like
kind of like saigon guys not seeing a
whole hell of a lot of distinctions here
the only distinction is that afghanistan
is
is a landlocked country so you're not
going to see the boat people but that's
about it
meaning there's no place for a lot of
these folks to go
the capital could fall into taliban
hands in a matter of weeks a military
analysis said the city could be isolated
in the next 30 to 60 days be captured in
90 days but now that seems like an
outside timeline because the taliban are
just running roughshod across the
country the taliban are denying reports
its fighters are executing afghan troops
but the u.s embassy said on thursday it
was hearing additional reports of
taliban executions of surrendering
afghan troops they said they were deeply
disturbing and could constitute war
crimes well i mean if they constitute
war crimes i guess we'll have to do
something about that like nothing
like like i don't even understand what
you're talking about at this point if
joe biden said there are no conditions
under which we go back in or insert
troops or anything like that so you
mouthing off and writing angry letters
to the taliban is likely to accomplish
precisely zero except to make you look
like an idiot which is exactly what joe
biden looks like today
the taliban have also detained several
members of the afghan government
including both civilian leaders and
officers in the afghan national defense
and security forces in several locations
god we are just the worst allies
seriously like all the people who worked
with us are gonna get shot they're gonna
get shot in the head in the public
square and joe biden is just gonna go
and that was unnecessary because again
zero combat deaths in the united states
from american troops zero combat deaths
since february of 2020.
okay it's one thing to make the argument
we need to pull out of afghanistan
because the costs are too high in 2011.
it is another thing to say that when you
are talking about zero combat deaths
most of the fighting by the way being
done by civilian contractors who are
getting paid for the privilege
like i don't even i don't even know how
with a straight face the us embassy
under joe biden or the state department
can talk about human rights violations
by the taliban like they're going to do
a damn thing about it they're not going
to
i don't know why america's allies would
trust us like this is the real takeaway
the takeaway is if you're an american
ally do you feel comfortable right now
relying on america's ability to back you
up
do you
the people of hong kong relied on the
west to back them up and now they're all
living under the tender mercies of
communist rule
the the kurds relied on the united
states to protect them that didn't work
out particularly well for the kurds
the afghans relied on the united states
to ally with them in order to overthrow
the taliban and now all those people can
get shot in the head and all the women
are going to get all the women are going
to cram back into burqas and acid thrown
on their faces and all the rest
like who wants to who takes the risk of
doing anything in alliance with the
united states when the united states
acts like this isn't it more likely that
countries in order to preserve
themselves are simply going to start
cutting deals with for example the
chinese
isn't that more likely the case like if
you're a country in the middle let's say
you're a country a european country
and the united states says listen china
is a rising threat china's aggressive
they are they're vindictive they pursue
human rights abuses they're some of the
worst people on the planet in the in the
chinese government and we need you to
help us isolate the chinese
if you're an american ally
and let's say you're an american ally in
the middle east like the saudis or the
israelis or let's say you're an american
ally in europe like the germans or the
french
why in the world would you rely on the
united states to back your play i just
don't understand
it doesn't make any
if you wish the united the united states
has to be credible in two ways it has to
have credible threats and it also has to
have credible commitments and we don't
have credible threats at this point and
we also don't have credible commitments
at this point
the arrests by the way contradict the
taliban's claim to support a negotiated
settlement and contrast the taliban's
own rhetoric providing for the safety of
afghan leaders and troops in areas
recently seized by the taliban according
to the u.s embassy
critics are saying the biden
administration is foolish to count on
promises made by the taliban in qatar
while taliban continues to just run
roughshod over the entire country and do
whatever the hell they want secretary of
state anthony blinken told abc news the
reported atrocities were quote deeply
deeply troubling but the administration
has not taken any action to punish the
group for them in fact the
administration just sounds weak and
pathetic
okay i'll give you an example here's how
weak and pathetic the administration
sounds here's jen saki from the white
house talking about the taliban and
their human rights abuses the taliban
also has to make an assessment about
what they want their role to be in the
international community and i know that
ambassador khalil azad made comments
when he was at the political
negotiations yesterday making clear that
the international community is going to
watch closely how the taliban behaves
they have a range of tools in their
arsenal as well to take steps should
they choose oh boy what are you going to
do leverage economic sanctions against a
bunch of cavemen from the 8th century
i'm sure they're quaking in their boots
they've been in caves
for the last 20 years i'm sure they're
really going to be upset if you guys
economic sanctions on the taliban wow
don't threaten them with a good time
i mean seriously this is unbelievable
like they have to decide i'm pretty sure
the taliban decided a long time ago
whether they wanted to be members of the
international community
such putz is over here in this
administration it's just unbelievable
like it's it it's it's insane gen they
have to decide well i mean they do have
to decide that
it's like
okay so you got the serial killer in the
corner and he's holding the woman in the
closet every so often he goes in and he
brings another victim and he just kills
one
that guy and we know he's doing it that
guy over there we have to decide whether
that guy he that man is gonna have to
decide whether he wants to be part of
the international community he's gonna
have to decide whether he wants to be
welcome at bingo night
or alternatively he's just gonna do
whatever the f he wants because you just
signified that you don't care don't
pretend you care when you don't care if
you want to own it own it seriously if
you don't care about what's happening
there just say you don't care about
what's happening there
that's at least an argument
but they want it both ways of course of
course
okay the cbs4 even even the members of
the media are saying this this is part
that drives me up a wall the members of
the media who spent the last
you know they spent eight years under
george w bush and then four years under
donald trump talking about how we
desperately needed to pull out from
afghanistan and then biden does it and
then the media are like well i hate that
the consequences here are terrible this
is yes you guys made those consequences
congratulations slow clap for all your
morons but here's the cbs reporter
saying to the state department
spokesperson you know you keep saying
you're with the afghan people i'm
noticing that you're not while they get
shot in the face
i respect you and like we know we all
have either you have a job to do but
there is no way you can sit there and
say that the people of afghanistan
watching the taliban take over provinces
watching their country crumble are now
going to watch american diplomats get on
military planes and leave the country
that that sends the signal that the u.s
is with them in the long haul
diplomatically
uh look at what we've been doing look at
the investments we have made in
afghanistan look at the investments
whether however you measure it okay
everyone is laughing at these people and
they should be laughing at these people
because they're pathetic okay in just
one second we'll get to more of this
because it really is it's an ignominious
end to this war and again to what
basically was just a continuous
peacekeeping mission that's all this was
in afghanistan it's pretty incredible
we'll get some more of it in a second
first most of my listeners already know
this but vincero is the premier maker of
men's and women's lifestyle products
checking sunglasses wallets watches
jewelry
a great looking watch is a must so i'm a
luxury watch guy but here's the thing
most people can't afford to drop like
seven eight grand on a luxury watch
instead you want a watch that's not
going to cost you a fortune but it looks
like it should cost you a bunch of money
and that's where vincero comes in
vincero is loved by some of your
favorite entrepreneurs commentators and
hosts like me
i love my video products i've given
vincero products to pretty much every
member of my family they make great
birthday gifts these are hands down the
best products you can get for this price
point when you pick up one of their
watches or sunglasses you immediately
know you got more than you paid for it
is the best value for your money
guaranteed which is why they offer a
five year warranty and a 365-day return
policy because they stand behind the
products they make right now is the
perfect time to shop vincero because
right now is their big anniversary
celebration this won't just be the
biggest sale of the year but the biggest
sale in ventura history it's up to 25
site-wide you won't be able to get a
ventura watch at a more affordable price
outside of the sale they even have a
brand new anniversary automatic watch
they just released and i love my
automatic watches head on over to
vincero collective dot com forward slash
shapiro that's v i n c e r o collective
dot com forward slash shapiro no code
required your discount will be
automatically applied to checkout but
only if you use that specific website
vincerocollective.com
shapiro everything on the site is up to
25 off no exclusions that include
sunglasses wallets and bracelets go to
my link check out vincero's big sale
today alrighty so
this is all it's amazing to watch this
administration spin as though they're
just not abandoning these folks and
again you want to abandon them make the
case make the case why they should be
abandoned make the case why the
sacrifice that we are currently
undergoing not the sacrifice we
underwent for the last 20 years the
sacrifice we are currently undergoing
is unnecessary
i haven't heard virtually anybody make
that case i keep hearing phrases like
endless wars thrown around without
recognition of the fact that we had 3
500 troops on the ground and zero combat
deaths in the last 18 months like i keep
hearing phraseology thrown around about
look how much money we've already spent
which is sort of like saying that you
buy a house and let's say the house is
money pet like it's a complete money pit
and you spend hundreds of thousands of
dollars to upgrade this house and it's
eaten up your savings
so after you're done right and now
you're living in the house it's got some
maintenance issues but you know you're
living there and you've already spent a
lot of so you decide you know what
because i spent a lot of money here over
the last 10 years i'm out now it just
abandons in the house that makes no
sense why would you do that again the
question is not what we've spent in the
past or whether that's justified there
are serious questions about that the
question is why are we leaving now and
the answer is because joe biden is a
boob a rube and a that is the
answer
there's no other answer that is possible
you know that he's gone completely wrong
when even the washington post editorial
board is like guys this dude is screwing
things up in a radical way the
washington post their editorial board
they uh they put up a piece title afghan
lives ruined or lost will be part of
biden's legacy yeah no no bleep
according to the washington post
editorial board mr biden called it quits
he says because after 20 years of trying
to get kabul to govern effectively and
fight harder against the taliban there
was still no outright victory or
prospect of one but the united states
was stalemated not defeated there's a
difference and how big a difference may
soon become tragically apparent in
addition to preventing terrorists from
using afghanistan as a base for another
911 the united states achieved or at
least oversaw real progress for the
people of afghanistan when the taliban
ruled between 1996 and 2001 it forbade
schooling for girls by 2015 the last
year for which world bank data exist
more than 50 percent of girls attended
first grade in 2006 the cohort american
university of afghanistan which now
enrolls over 1700 students opened in
kabul supported by us government funds
it has partnerships with stanford the
uc's university of california and the
university of nebraska
a massive terrorist attack in 2016
forced the auaf to close it courageously
reopened in 2017. most afghans live in
unfathomable in unfathomable poverty but
today's per capita income of around 550
bucks per year is still a 66 improvement
in real terms since 2002.
biden surveys the impending disaster and
absolve himself of any responsibility he
says it's up to afghan leaders to come
together he said they've got to fight
for themselves the truth is they had
been fighting but the united states had
trained them to do it with the support
of u.s advisors and contractors suddenly
all the support is just gone
the biden administration says it will
take care of people who work directly
for the united states
in a real sense though this country
assumed at least a partial
responsibility for the afghan people and
now we are abandoning them of course
that is very largely true and you know
the video coming out from afghanistan is
not pretty the bbc has a report about
what life is like under restored taliban
rule suffice it to say it doesn't look
like people living in brooklyn
the market is still busy
women have apparently been allowed to
come here without male companions if
they need to
but elsewhere taliban commanders have
reportedly banned them
you don't wear
the next day a young woman was killed
close by allegedly for wearing immodest
clothing many fear the taliban want to
resurrect their practice of brutal
punishments
they insist they were not responsible
for this flogging supposedly filmed last
year many people here in afghanistan and
around the world
would be
horrified at the idea of a society where
hands are cut women are stoned to death
it says we're bringing this judge is it
better to let these crimes go in
punishment
you mean the crime of like walking
around
without your head covered in a bag like
that that crime right there
yeah things are things are going
beautifully over there by the way how
pathetic is america right now here's how
pathetic america is this story is unreal
okay this is from the new york times u.s
asks taliban to spare its embassy in
coming fight for kabul
we are basically asked we are begging
the worst people on the planet the
taliban to at least give us the optical
grace of not burning down our embassy
you know it's okay if you take over the
country and you kill all of the people
who worked with us and you acid all the
women who go to school and you beat
people in the street and sometimes shoot
them in the street that's all okay
please if you could just not burn our
embassy so there aren't these ugly
pictures on cnn and they get people mad
at us that would be amazing
pathetic with a capital p according to
the new york times american negotiators
are trying to extract assurances from
the taliban that they will not attack
the u.s embassy in kabul if the
extremist group takes over the country's
government and ever wants to receive
foreign aid three american officials
said foreign aid the f you talk it to
the taliban
to you
what
don't burn our capital if you ever want
us to sign you a check
under what circumstances would we be
signing checks to the taliban
the people who literally are murdering
all of the people we allied ourselves
with
this is i mean this is legitimately one
of the most pathetic things i've ever
heard in terms of american foreign
policy we are now begging the taliban a
ragtag group of 8th century primitives
we are begging them to not burn our
capital uh to not burn our embassy
because if they burn our embassy maybe
we won't sign them a welfare check
according to the new york times the
effort led by zalmai khalilzad the chief
american envoy and talks with the
taliban seeks to stave off a full
evacuation of the embassy as they
rapidly see cities across afghanistan on
thursday the state department announced
it was sending home an unspecified
number of the 1400 american station at
the embassy and drawing down what the
agency's spokesperson ned price
described as a core diplomatic presence
in kabul
by the way the the pentagon spokesperson
announcing this thing i mean this is
just it's pathetic it's pathetic
pathetic footage
and i will say that america's response
to all of this to to the insanity of
what's going on
it's even more pathetic the us embassy
put out a statement about the
the detention by the taliban of members
of the afghan government here is the
statement put out by the embassy of the
united states of america the most
powerful country in the history of the
world again to a bunch of ragtag cavemen
from the 8th century quote the us
embassy in afghanistan condemns
detention of afghan officials we
strongly condemn the unlawful arrest of
several members of the afghan government
including both civilian leaders and
officers of the afghan national defense
and security forces credible sources
indicate that the taliban have detained
provincial government officials and
members of the afghan police in several
locations these actions are unacceptable
and they contradict the taliban's claim
to support a negotiated settlement in
the ongoing doha peace process the
actions also contrast the taliban's own
rhetoric providing for the safety of
afghan leaders and troops in areas
recently seized by the taliban we're
urging the immediate release of all
afghan government officials detained by
the taliban and we are calling on the
taliban to fully and earnestly engage in
negotiations that end the suffering of
the afghan people and pave the way for
an inclusive political settlement that
benefits all afghans that's gonna work
guys
wait a man up there that's totally gonna
work
hey you mean a weakly and vaguely worded
you're urging the taliban to not execute
the people they oppose well then i mean
that that radically
until then the taliban were just like
we're gonna do whatever the hell we want
and execute all of our enemies but now
that you put out a statement urging them
not to do so for the sake of miss
congeniality-esque world peace that's
going to change the math on the ground
nobody ever asked them to be nice before
now that somebody's asked them to be
nice i think that'll change everything
but
again there are no words for how
pathetic this is
and remember the people who are
currently dancing in the offices of the
governor of koshini not only lack rhythm
they lack a basic sense of
civilization and human decency these are
the worst people on earth there's some
video that emerged from afghanistan of
taliban fighters dancing around
honestly they have even worse rhythm
than i do which is saying an awful lot
all right here's some of that footage
apparently good at humiliating the biden
state department very bad at dancing
also that's that music is not okay
that's enough of that okay
meanwhile by the way the vacuum is being
filled remember afghanistan's not the
only country on the planet and the
taliban are the only group we have to
worry about china is now preparing to
recognize the taliban because china is
completely transactional china is
entirely transactional understand that
us abandoning afghanistan does not mean
that some group will never hear of again
is going to take over it means that the
chinese government will cut a deal with
the taliban to extract natural resources
the chinese government will strengthen
itself if you think of china as a
serious long-term threat to the
viability of the american project which
you should because they're incredibly
aggressive then it should trouble you
that china has now extended its
tentacles ever more
westward according to u.s news china is
now preparing to recognize the taliban
as the legitimate ruler of afghanistan
if it succeeds in toppling the
western-backed government in kabul the
u.s news has learned a prospect that
undercuts the biden administration's
remaining source of leverage over the
insurgent network as it continues its
startling campaign to regain control
beijing has publicly pressured the
taliban to continue working toward a
peace agreement and outcome china
appears to genuinely prefer and won the
us's press with growing urgency but new
chinese military and intelligence
assessments of the realities on the
ground have prompted leaders in the
chinese communist party to prepare to
formalize their relationship with the
insurgent network according to multiple
us and foreign intelligence sources
familiar with the chinese assessments so
while the biden administration's like
guys please don't burn our embassy
because we might not send you 4nh hyun
is like if you burn their embassy you're
still going to get foreign aid guys
we're going to be your friends
okay china does not care with whom they
make a deal they don't care about the
human rights of the people whom they
make a deal because they're a human
rights violator themselves they are a
tyrannical overlordship
and they are a real threat to american
interests globally
isolationism is not a solution to your
opponents wanting to expand their power
if the taliban want to claim an
international legitimacy these actions
will not get them the legitimacy they
seek said white house spokeswoman
shinsaki
they should devote the same energy to
the peace process as they do to the
military campaign or alternatively they
could ignore you and then just make a
deal with the chinese
so all of this is going extremely
extremely well this is a massive failure
on the part of the biden administration
and they need to own it they need to own
it in the same way that barack obama had
to own the rise of isis this is way
worse this is way worse at least you can
make an argument with regard to isis
that isis was a small ragtag ban when we
pulled out of iraq
this is significantly worse we all know
what's happening in real time this is
not like we leave and then isis
gradually rises and suddenly six months
later we're worried about it we're
watching the bad guys take over kabul
now
and biden is like
well you know
matlock's on
amazing stuff alrighty in just one
second we'll get to the continued
madness over covered and it grows
increasingly mad i mean it's just the
insanity is never i don't think that
that our our centralizing bureaucracy is
ever going to stop ever ever ever first
let's talk about a simple fact you need
home insurance everybody needs home
insurance in fact in many states it's
mandatory if you buy a home you need
home insurance why wouldn't you
competitively shop that policy genius
makes it easy to compare home and auto
insurance in one place they can help you
find home and auto coverage similar to
what you have now but at a lower price
they've saved their customers an average
of 1 250 bucks per year over what they
were paying for home and auto insurance
they've saved their new customers an
average of 435 bucks per year on auto
insurance and they save new customers an
average of 350 bucks per year on home
insurance that's a lot of money head on
over to policygenius.com shapiro home
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property and then
policy genius will take it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
and find your lowest quotes the policy
genius team can look for ways to save
you more including bundling those home
and auto policies and if they find a
better rate than what you're paying
right now they'll switch you over for
free there's a reason they have five
star reviews thousands of them across
trustpilot and google head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro home get
started right now policy genius when it
comes to insurance it's nice and very
very important to get it right go check
them out right now at policygenius.com
shapiro home to get started today all
right we'll get to everything covert
related in just one second first it is
that incredible time of the week when i
give a shout out to a daily wire member
today it's anthony thomas on instagram
who understands quality parenting and
quality products in this magnificent
picture anthony's young son is out on
the lengths holding his golf club in one
hand and the world's greatest beverage
vessel in the other the caption reads
nothing keeps my sweet tea cold on the
golf course quite like my leftist tears
tumbler dad may not let me listen to all
of ben shapiro but he does talk to us a
lot about a lot of the topics and that's
that's some good dating right there
thanks for the pic and thanks for being
a daily ware member also you may have
noticed that america is at a turning
point that the authoritarians seem to be
on the ascendant in pretty much every
area of american life from the
institutions that you work for to your
social media institutions to your media
and yes to your local state and federal
government my book the authoritarian
moment breaks it all down for you and
tells you how to fight back it is a
massive national bestseller thank you i
appreciate that if you've already bought
the book if you have not you're missing
out go check it out right now the
authoritarian moment is now available at
amazon barnes noble or any other major
bookseller go get your copy right now
leave a five star review if you like
what you read
other things happening well you know
candace owens you love candace owens but
right now she's opening her studio to
one lucky vip winner this is like
this is like willy wonka and the golden
ticket right here if you sign up right
now as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 25 off your new membership
and be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two you and a
guest to the daily wear studios to see
candace live you're not only going to
meet candace you'll get an inside look
at her studio you'll get front row seats
to watch her take down leftist live and
in action on her talk show canada so get
a great deal on a new dailywear
membership at dailywire.com subscribe
with code vip and 25 off so you can
automatically be entered for a chance to
win the vip experience
also we have a new product out you know
about it you love it it's morning wire
it's our daily news podcast it's been
topping the apple and spotify charts
since its recent release it is
conservative oriented it is short it is
fast it gets you all the news you need
to know and it's honest with
editor-in-chief john bickley my personal
pick to replace me as editor-in-chief of
daily wire and co-host georgia hal
morning wire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture and education all with a heavy
emphasis on the facts in 15 bite size
minutes perfect for your daily commute
so again subscribe and listen to morning
wire on apple podcast spotify and
everywhere you listen to podcasts so you
don't miss a beat if you like what you
hear leave a five star review tell the
podcast platforms conservative news
belongs at number one on the charts you
are listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
already meanwhile everybody is panicking
about coveted the panic continues how
bad is the panic at this point the
philadelphia mayor has now ordered the
unvaccinated in philadelphia to wear not
one but two masks in fact probably the
philadelphia mayor jim kenny he should
order them to wear infinity masks like
it'll just come off their face go all
the way around the world until it hits
them in the back of the head again like
that's the only way to truly know that
we are safe from covid
he is now announcing beginning september
1st all government employees must be
fully vaccinated or they will be
required to double mask when working in
enclosed spaces but wait a second why do
we need a double mask i was told that
single masks are good i was told that if
you even questioned the efficacy of
single masks then then you would be
thrown off of youtube right but he's
saying you need double masks or as
anthony fauci says if one mask is good
perhaps a second mask would be even
better or maybe a third or maybe a
fourth maybe a ninth mask
really really exciting stuff by the way
the vaccines continue to be extremely
effective against death which is the
only thing that i care about
there no one at any point has explained
to me how the moral compass here is
supposed to work what's the end goal
what's the limiting principle
uh really there is no limiting principle
by the logic of the lockdown advocates
and the mass vaccine advocates and the
vaccine mandate people
the logic seems to be that so long as
disease is with us on planet earth you
must mask up vaccinated or unvaccinated
which means you will be masking up until
the end of time
end of story and your kids will be
masking up until the end of time
to prevent deaths that are entirely
preventable so long as you get the
vaccine
like
what
there's no logic here none
and yet
all that the left has just gone back to
the playbook the playbook is if you are
in favor of any level of human freedom
at all you're pro-death this is joy reid
being her usual idiotic self
the governor of florida ron desantis
he's left he's leaving florida this
weekend to go do a fundraiser on a sheep
farm in nevada
that's what he thinks is important for
himself to do
you've got lawsuits in texas
in which travis county a judge has
batted down
the governor of texas the reality is
these governors are taking a stance in
favor of death and i don't understand
the calculation to do that
well because they're not they're not
they're balancing more than one factor
those factors include your rights to
human liberty
i understand that all you folks don't
give a damn about liberty you don't care
about freedom i mean arnold
schwarzenegger said yesterday he
literally said i don't care about
freedom your freedom is stupid to me
he's like
well i care about the freedom and you
should also care about like that sort of
language is not particularly useful
but again the notion is that you can do
whatever you want to be unvaccinated
because they are the real problem here
they're a real problem for them
okay meaning if you're unvaccinated this
is the decision you have made and
literally every person i know who is not
vaccinated has not asked me to mask up
i'm i'm vaccinated they've never asked
anything of me
it's only members of the government who
are asking something of me it is only
members of the liberal media who are
asking something of me not the
unvaccinated
the unvaccinated are willing to undergo
whatever risk they're willing to undergo
and that now means that that is their
problem because again the vaccines
remain incredibly effective despite all
of the coveted panic being propagated by
the media the headline a drudge right
now i kid you not the headline is
vaccine effectiveness spooks system that
is the giant headline
well why why why is that spooking the
system
according to axios the biden
administration is intensely scrutinizing
coronavirus vaccine's effectiveness over
time facing the daunting task of timing
booster shots right while still
convincing the unvaccinated that getting
the jab is worthwhile
well no if we find out that the
antibodies wane over time and if there's
no t cell immunity that is provided then
people will go get vaccinated again
because they got vaccinated in the first
place preliminary findings from the mayo
clinic
show
that the the pfizer vaccine is
preventing significantly fewer
infections now than it was before the
delta variant
but um who cares apparently the study
has raised alarm bells within the body
administration but again i ask who cares
i i don't care that pfizer is not
preventing you from getting the thing if
you're vaccinated because fires are is
preventing the only thing i care about
which is not dying i don't need to if if
i get a mild cold because i get infected
with covid after being vaccinated i feel
like i've dodged the bullet here
we don't even measure how many people
get a cold in the united states every
year because no one cares gang
and yet the idea here seems to be that
we have to measure case counts
so the big question according to axios
if the vaccines are losing some of their
punch against mild infections now
will they eventually become less
effective against severe disease
um
well when you provide me evidence that
they are and that i need to take a
booster i will go get the booster how
about that
right now they're still really effective
against preventing you from being dead
in texas there have been 291 vaccinated
people hospitalized which accounts for
0.2 of all coveted hospitalizations
there have been 52 breakthrough deaths
accounting for 0.4
of all deaths
the hospitalization rate for the
vaccinated in texas is 4 per 100 000
people for the unvaccinated it's 735 per
100 000 people in fact in texas this is
according to meteorite unvaccinated
people in texas are 185 times more
likely to be hospitalized and they are
85 times more likely to die from covet
so get the vacs
or don't get the backs
you're gonna
that's all
and here's the thing that's so ironic
about all this the media the same media
who are ripping on ron desantis and uh
ron to say oh look at the texas in
florida
i've noticed that they have nothing to
say about louisiana where the governor
is a democrat also you will notice that
the media have a very different take on
you depending on your identity if you
decide not to get vaccinated so if
you're a white rural trump voter from
tennessee you're bad and evil and
endangering everyone and the
and the epsilon
variant
the
phi variant may eventually come from you
however if you're a black inner city
person you decided not to get the
vaccine this is because you have a
justified suspicion of the government
according to the new york times today
quote why only 28 of young black new
yorkers are vaccinated
as the delta variant courses through new
york city many young black new yorkers
remain distrustful of the vaccine
a construction site safety manager in
queens said that as a black man he was
more worried about the prospect of being
stopped by the police than he was about
getting coveted 19. a grad suit by the
way that's crazy
okay i'm sorry that's crazy like your
chances of being shot unarmed by the
police in the united states as a black
man fewer than 20 people in the united
states meet this definition
every year in the united states you know
many black people have died of covet 19
many many many because lots of people
have died overall from covenant 19. a
graduate student in the bronx who had
not gotten vaccinated said her worst
fear seemed confirmed when a vaccine
that the government was directing to
black and poorer neighborhoods was
briefly suspended over a small number of
dangerous blood clots and a civil rights
activist in the bronx said he grew
suspicious when he heard last year that
politicians were prioritizing minority
neighborhoods for coveted vaccines so in
other words this civil rights activist
a black lives matter activist named hawk
newsome who you've heard of he's 44. he
said that he got suspicious of the
vaccine specifically because the
government was trying to make sure that
black people got it so in other words if
the government does not try to make sure
that black people especially get it it's
because systemic racism but if the
government tries to make sure that black
people get it also systemic racism
because maybe the government is trying
to target you
since when does america give anything
good to black people first said the
activist hawkinson
all three situations according to the
new york times reflect a trend that has
become a major concern to public health
experts young black new yorkers are
especially reluctant to get vaccinated
even as the delta variant is rapidly
spreading among their ranks city data
show only 28 of black new yorkers aged
18 to 44 are fully vaccinated compared
to 48 of latino residents and 52 percent
of white residents in that age group
this vaccination gap is emerging as the
latest stark racial disparity in an
epidemic full of them
this is a major public health failure
said dr dustin duncan an epidemiologist
and columbia university professor god
the soft bigotry of low expectations is
just incredible isn't it so if you're a
rural white voter now this is because
you are a dum-dum and a and you
voted for trump if you're a black urban
voter and you decided that you weren't
going to get vaccinated this is a public
health failure everyone out the system
failed you and if the system tried to
get you to take the vaccine it's because
the system might be racist
my god the media are terrible at this
and not just terrible at this damaging
at this when you grant legitimacy to
this particular point of view are you
surprised when people then don't get
vaccinated
utter insanity and madness
by the way you want to talk about utter
insanity and madness the american
academy of pediatrics just put out a
statement saying
that children do not need to study faces
i'm not kidding you
they put out a statement saying babies
and young children study faces so you
may worry that having masked caregivers
would harm children's language
development there are no studies to
support this concern young children will
use other clues like gestures and tone
of voice
that's not okay that is so unrooted
there are no studies to support that oh
you mean we haven't had any longitudinal
studies about children not looking at
faces because that's torturing children
because that would basically be an
illegal study like if you were to take a
subgroup of children and be like half of
these babies get to look at human faces
talking half of these babies will be
deprived of looking at human faces for a
year that literally would not be allowed
okay that would be violative of research
protocols because it would damage babies
one of the problems with autism is that
people cannot read facial expressions
okay teaching kids not to be able to
read facial expressions is the height of
idiocy
this is ridiculous one of the things
that kids learn first is how to mirror
facial expressions you see this even in
prime mates the way that baby primates
operate is they mirror the facial
expressions of older primates of course
it's damaging
of course it is
i remember my wife doing actual research
on this when she worked in a
neuroscience lab between the time she
went to college and the time she went to
medical school she worked in a
neuroscience lab with a rather famous
professor who's doing studies on this
sort of stuff yes it makes a difference
that children look at human faces
this is insane
you're just now now the aap the american
academy of pediatrics is saying screw
the kids kids don't need to see faces
because we have to continue to push this
nonsense that all children need to mask
up
based on precisely zero substantiated
studies at this point
like this is this is crazy
by the way here's a piece from
fortune.com as delta infection spiked
coveted cases in schools actually fell
a lesson from england for parents wary
of sending their kids off to school
here's a rare bit of comforting data
fewer than 1 in 100 school students and
staff in england tested positive for
cover 19 in june the capper there was no
mass mandate in the schools at the time
that wasn't just a noticeable drop from
last autumn it also came as delta
varying cases were peaking not just
across england but the whole of the uk
an estimated 0.27 percent of elementary
school students 0.42 of middle to high
school students and 0.27 percent of
teachers tested positive for cova 19
between june 14th and july 6. this is
compared with autumn 2020 when around 1
of elementary school students and staff
tested positive while 1.22 of high
school students and 1.64 of staff tested
positive
okay so um why
why so they say maybe there's additional
testing at the schools
or maybe there's just no evidence to
bath this sort of stuff by the way there
are plenty of studies showing that face
masks compare how we reach how we read
emotions there's one particularly from
frontiers in psychology it cites 65
other studies talking about how people
need to see faces in order to interpret
emotions this is perfectly obvious
but we live in such an illogical stupid
society that things that we've accepted
as writ for literally all of human
existence
are now being we're being asked to
defend them it's like well can you
explain to me why looking at human faces
is good for you
can you explain me why we shouldn't all
just be working or walking around in a
burka i mean what's the problem it'll
protect you from the virus and also
you'll be abiding by taliban like
fundamentalist law like what you'll
you'll be hitting so many green check
marks for yourself like i
we all understand that not wearing a
mask is a good thing
the fact that we're being asked to
defend this on the basis of like really
really shoddy public data
is completely crazy it's just completely
crazy at this point alrighty well we
have reached the end of this week but we
will be back here next week for much
much more i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
widowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our new
show morning wire on today's episode a
battle over masked mandates erupts in
texas oregon schools make big changes
over alleged racism and a hollywood me
too group is caught up in a me too
scandal join us and get the facts first
on the news you need to know with our
show morning wire